Ah
[laughter]
I'm a tori city Minami Ward Respeel who
uses a sale Please walk with me Iwaishimajutsu What can you do when you
use
it?
It's an arm that's been burned by God's flames
If you look closely, it
's just a title production
Hikaru Noguchi 6 days for me
And I swear to my god
[music]
Strong proximity makes it easier to get what you want
But instead come nam get caught up in your destiny It
's a commonly said story
Wow my ginger I give
you as your key  It's painful to be weak I have to
throw away your cad -
Sky glass Beer balls I won't blame you I
wanted to gain protection It
's a shame I really wanted to add you to my camp
Defeating a
variety
of errands I'm a young hero and I'm dead, but it's
okay I know what to do
[Music]
[Applause]
At that time
, the cage
of Gricefeel Peace and water for the souls of the dead
Narita 0 c Nursing and earnest wish  Eight Views n
[Music]